foreign
just want to ask you about 81st just
your level of concern with him after he
took that shot
um I didn't see the shot
um I'm just saying the aftermath but you
know um
medical team seems to say he's been he's
doing better so
you know that's what matters the most
how much of a part of that is it do you
figure now as you get back for game six
the situation you've been in before
maybe a little bit of uncertainty about
A.D but how do you approach this as a
leader hunt going back in the plane uh
we have another opportunity
um obviously they you know played
exceptionally well here tonight and uh
you know we have some some good moments
but you know not as close to 48 minutes
as we needed to be but I'm going to have
opportunity on Friday but of course into
the matchup again
LeBron was a tied game with about four
minutes to go in the second quarter and
then we know this is a team that can go
around was there anything when you think
back to late second quarter early third
that you felt like on your end
contributed not your team's end that
contributed to that run uh I mean we
kind of made a run we had an opportunity
to um
you know I missed the easy jump hook in
the lane to kind of cut the lead to
three um 80 right after that I missed
the jump hook he had an opportunity to
have a tip dunk missed it we blew a
coverage clay hit a three on that right
wing put him up eight
and then we came back down missed again
and then Steph hit the big one at the
end of the quarter so we know that
they're a team of runs and
you know you got to be able to match
that and it just kept it going in the
third obviously
the brown I have two for you um the
conversation in the last 48 hours has
been from the Warriors standpoint it's
been gamesmanship on your team and
flopping did you feel like that affected
anything in terms of the way the game
was dealt with tonight on the court
um I just know that we uh you know our
coaching staff and US players we don't
we don't work on flopping
we don't it's not even a part of our
game our our game is to attack attack
the paint
um we don't mind physical contact we
actually like the contact but we don't
shy away from it so
um
which is not a team that
you know goes out there and looking for
for you know
flopping opportunities there's just not
us it's never been
there's actually never been to any team
that I've played on in my 20 years where
we've been a flopping team
you know but
it is what it is they have the right to
say what they want to say or you know
but the game is always one in between
the four lines and you know we better we
got to be better on Friday for sure
earlier today you were named to the all
NBA 13 I think this is 19 straight years
for you
knowing what you've done and dealt with
physically and stuff like that how does
this one hit differently in year 20.
um
I just I guess I only take those moments
for granted when you get an opportunity
to be recognized as one of the best
players still in the league and have one
of the best seasons you know and make
all NBA team
um you know I don't take my you know
anything I'll be able to accomplish for
for granted and I've always appreciative
for the
to be a part of any selection
um you know in this league so many great
players and so many great teams and a
lot of a lot of guys this year addicts
you know some some really good Seasons
some great seasons
to be a part of that uh that class of 15
guys when I seen the list is still
pretty cool you know even at my age and
where I'm at right now in year 20.
um you know don't just don't take it for
granted
and obviously I got bigger fish to fry
but you know no small mamas those small
Wings right there
um it's all part of I guess it's all
part of the journey all part of the
Legacy you know as far as what I do on
the floor you know in this league so
that's pretty cool
Lebron in uh there you go thank you
um in your career you've played in
plenty of game sixes where you have a
chance to clinch you also just had that
last series is there something that you
think this team this year needs to focus
on Friday in comparison to the Past
um
you know every moment is his own
Challenge and it's his own game and it's
his own uh you know opportunity to see
What You're Made Of and we can't base
last series on to this series this
series is different uh the opponent is
different the challenges is different so
um you know Friday it was another
opportunity for us to to see where we
are and see what we're made of
um and and to go out there with the um I
guess they've written the fight that
we've had since we came together after
the All-Star break very resilient team
and we respond well to adversity and uh
we look forward to that um
you know to get an opportunity to play
again on Friday
LeBron you guys are 6-0 between the
playing around first round through the
Warriors series at crypto.com this
postseason I want to know if you had any
message for Laker fans planning to come
to the game on Friday
um well we didn't handle our business
tonight so
you know I look forward to seeing our
fans you know for another game in the
second round but you know
those six games are out the window it's
over and done with so you know our job
is to try to be one and on Friday you
know and uh you know I look forward you
know to that opportunity last question
yeah LeBron uh last game six you guys
played you said you guys approached it
like game seven mentality didn't want to
go back to Memphis for game seven is
that assume the same approach going to
this one yeah it's the same
it's the same
appreciate it